we're Midway through a spring season
that's on Pace to meet all the
expectations with awesome sequels and
anticipated shows like oshinoko knocking
it out of the park and things can only
get better here on out so now's a better
time they need to start looking ahead
into the summer season a famed season of
Blockbusters what does summer have in
store for us in the world of anime come
join me as we take a tour of what the
coming season has to offer and check out
the most anticipated amongst the
upcoming summer anime we start off with
what seems like a blast from the past in
reign of the seven spellblades
the prestigious Magic School Kimberly
welcomes new students Every Spring
complete with lavish parades to welcome
aspiring upstarts it's the perfect
Academy where nothing bad ever happens
our protagonist Oliver horn enters the
bright Gates of Kimberley and quickly
gets acquainted with his new friends and
a sword-wielding girl he takes a
particular interest in short the
curricular may be rough at times and so
are the instructors but it's nothing too
out of the blue right however things do
seem amiss and when night falls there
may be more to the magic Academy than
meets the eye Dark Secrets lie Beyond
its wall waiting to be discovered by
those daring ones water weights are two
students in their foray into the abyss a
brainchild of the guy who brought us
Alder ramen in the sky reign of the
seven spellblades takes the magic
Academy premise that was popular in the
2010s and takes it through a
surprisingly dark and heavy term doing
away with the usual overpowered
protagonist shtick these shows tend to
have this title looks to give us a more
cynical Outlook at the genre but it's
surely a magical ride that seasoned
anime fans can enjoy
[Music]
coming up next at number nine is helk
RI
foreign
with the defeat of the demon king and
the celebration of humanity it's time to
go back to the drawing board there's
nothing for the demons to do but to
regroup so they organized yet another
tournament to determine who will inherit
the title of demon king however there's
a bit of A Wrinkle In the proceedings
within the field of contenders the one
that's projected to win it all is none
other than a human hero Helk the same
guy who defeated the previous Demon King
and it's not that he's lucky in the
current tournament the guy easily beats
his demonic competition all while
proclaiming his hatred for Humanity
looking to set things into order before
things get out of hand red vamirio seeks
to uncover Hulk's true intentions hell
Gaza manga is a title that creates a
great balance of serious and
light-hearted with the wacky premise
comes a lot of comedic moments as we get
to see the developing relationship
between the over-the-top hero and
sundere Demon their journey is a lot of
fun to follow and intertwined between
those light-hearted moments are some
surprisingly heavy content that really
caught me off guard it's a wacky show
with a wacky set of characters but it's
something you won't regret watching even
if you're a fan of the more serious
shows
thank you
we proceed to the next entry dark
Gathering
foreign
being spiritually attuned has its major
downsides for the ghost hating gitaro it
takes a drastic turn bad experiences and
is not for attracting Spirits sets him
on the path to becoming a shut-in
something that he's only now trying to
overcome with the help of his childhood
friend Aiko one of his steps in his
Rehabilitation involves taking a job as
a tutor and as luck would have it
however he finds himself tutoring Aiko's
cousin yayoi someone who's just as
spiritually attuned as he is yayoi on
the other hand yearns to encounter
spirits and suddenly gerdaro finds
himself slowly drifting away from the
job's original purpose and delving back
into the world of spirits that he hated
the supernatural genre has had a
Resurgence in the past couple of years
it seems you've got to thank Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen for that and to a lesser extent
some new anime for all-time favorites
like bleach that keep the momentum going
for those looking for a more
horror-oriented take on the genre as
opposed to action you may fancy dark
Gathering it starts off strong and
really holds you tight with a series of
Cliffhangers that always keeps you on
your toes it's got the creepy Factor
down and it's looking to be one of the
more promising hits this season
hello
this summer also sees the return of
Barky
foreign
if you think you've seen it all in the
world of fighting anime well you're not
prepared for what vaki's got in store
for you the thing is wild and so over
the top and just when you think it's all
over the next part of barkiharma
promises to one-up things even more
that's a lot to say about this show
considering it's got action scenes that
go really hard and people throwing out
insane Feats like nothing I mean just
check this out how about seeing our
protagonists go face to face with a
million year old Neanderthal who's sure
to give him a run for his money and that
isn't even the tip of the iceberg as to
what's to come in Barky as a whole if
you're fond of some high octane violence
and over-the-top action the time they
can give JoJo a run for its money
there's no reason not to get started on
Barky and if you're caught up with it
why are you letting this next season
pass you by
Superstar
[Music]
now before we move on to more exciting
anime on the list I'd like to take the
time to thank today's sponsors captor
Clash Captain Clash is a thrilling
mobile game that lets you experience
action RPG goodness on the go with nice
graphics and gameplay that's easy to get
the hang of there's no better travel
partner for you than this game I really
like capture Clash for the whole anime
aesthetic the game's got that down pat
and with the slew of Heroes to choose
from this is one of the best fighters
for the person who wants their Quick Fix
I'm digging these designs for real too
match yourself with people from all over
the world while you're at it with how
quick the game is to pick up and the
number of characters to choose from
you'll quickly find those hours fly away
as you spend time tinkering and
mastering this game it's one of the best
fighting games you can grab for the
mobile phone and if the gameplay and
Aesthetics aren't enough to convince you
perhaps these rewards for new players
will check these out
awesome
[Applause]
great gameplay called character designs
and lots of rewards waiting for you
there's no better time to start captor
Clash than today check out the link in
the description box if you want to take
the dip into this up and coming fighting
game and we can have our fun together
now back to the show zom100 is up next
at man am I excited for this one
foreign
dead inside is something people these
days often use to describe themselves
but for 24 year old Akira he embodies
that phrase completely broken by the
mundane Life as a cog in the stressful
machine that's the Japanese work system
he looks to just waste his life away if
only there could be an event to give
some spice in his life right well that
which becomes a reality when he Bears
witness to his landlord eating another
tenant turns out the entire city is
teeming with zombies and while it's not
exactly the ideal situation for a person
like Akira is the type of thrill that
makes him feel even more alive than
before the race against doomsday begins
with him looking to finish up his bucket
list of things to do Zone 100 looks to
be one of those knee shits featuring a
character relatable to a sizable chunk
of the anime consuming audience and
while setting the auto keeper surprised
it's a good blend of comedy and
flashiness to get people hooked on this
insane ride and it could very well be
the Hidden Gem of the season
stray dogs returns and it's here for its
fifth season
if you went back into time say around a
decade ago and told me that they'd be
committing this much to bungo stray dogs
I wouldn't have been surprised but five
seasons in and here we are with more of
this sane and Blockbuster that continues
to Captivate its fans whether you're
someone who loves it for the Intriguing
setup and world or just prefers its
fights if you like Bongo stray dogs in
any capacity than this Fifth Season
ought to be on your radar for the fifth
season which I personally think should
have been called season four part two we
continue with the Sky Casino Arc right
where we were left with a cliffhanger
the last time around the best part of
the arc is yet to come so that ought to
get you excited for the climax of this
interesting storyline Bongo stray dogs
has been decently consistent with its
quality and you should expect all the
same kind of anime goodness in this
fifth season
is the next in line to make its big
return
has been one of the most influential
titles in the 90s and it's shown that in
a big way with a lot of supplementary
material live-action adaptations and
such the rides not nearly over yet
however as we're here in the year 2023
awaiting a remake that I honestly didn't
see coming it's true however and Ronnie
Kenshin will be remade as an anime
looking to retell the story to new anime
fans there are many things that gave
Rurouni Kenshin the reputation it has
ranging from Great Character writing a
great sense of stakes and tension and
some of the most iconic scenes that 90s
kids still Rave about today the story of
the wandering swordsman is a Timeless
tale and there's no reason why the youth
in the modern era wouldn't be able to
appreciate one of the best examples of
anime writing genius from back in the
day I am a fan so I can't wait for this
modernized take on the classic but even
if you've never heard of Rurouni Kenshin
before then just give it a try if the
anime team doesn't mess this up big time
it's going to be worth your time
demo
says
speaking of continuations of Legacy
series bleach looks to continue its role
this summer
foreign
to say that bleacher's return has been a
resounding success would be underselling
it it's by far the biggest and most
glorious recovery I've seen for a legacy
series around a decade ago it was quite
a polarizing series with its fair share
of criticism but you wouldn't remember
that time after watching Thousand-Year
blood War and seeing the insane
reception it got the whole change in
tone and cutting away filler really did
wonders and it helped the series like
Demon Slayer and Jiu Jitsu Kaizen helped
pave the way for this comeback well
everyone's ready for more and bleach
thousand year blood War makes its return
this summer The last part ended with
some crazy Revelations and a cliffhanger
that kept everyone waiting expect to see
even more intense fights in this season
with both Shinigami and Quincy about to
release the big guns in their upcoming
fights we'll also get a battle that
wasn't presented in the manga so that's
something to look forward to Thousand
Year blood War has been excellent in
supplementary content and this new fight
is something that really gets me hyped
up
foreign
[Music]
probably one of the most well-made
isakai titles in the past few years all
eyes are on the second season of mushoku
tensei the first season made waves
showing a very balanced take on the
genre giving us everything the fans want
from the tropes to the excellent World
building rudius's journey and Adventures
in the first season have been very
captivating so who's excited to see how
things go when he grows a little bit
older new challenges new dangers their
weight in this next chapter along with
the return of who I feel was a very
underrated character in the first season
there's a lot to be excited for in the
second season of mushoku tensei but I'll
say that it's not exactly an anime you
can appreciate completely without
watching it from the start so go and
start watching the first season before
the summer isakai has never been this
well produced before if you absolutely
must watch an isakai then make it count
and go for mushoku tensei
[Music]
lastly we finished strong with the
second season of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
foreign
[Music]
has firmly established itself as one of
the biggest shown in Blockbusters of
this generation I've always said that
it's done that on the heels of
groundbreaking fight animation a very
strong cast of characters that feel
relevant and character dynamics that
keep you surprised with every twister
gets pulled on us we've spent the past
Season watching highlights of our main
Trio and especially Gojo and we've been
blessed with insane battles to remember
the best part of it all we're not even
at the exciting part yet Jiu Jitsu
kaizen's second season takes us to the
Shibuya Arc which for me is the peak of
the series as of the time of this
writing the stakes have never been
higher before and in between the great
fights and lots of moments that ought to
get us hyped and sad prepare yourself
for a whirlwind of emotions entering
this season and I'm not even sure all
that preparation is going to be enough I
can't wait for the Shibuya Arc and I'm
sure the Die Hard Jiu Jitsu Kaizen fans
have it way worse than I do
foreign
now which one is your favorite amongst
the shows listed do tell me in the
comments section down below once again
we thank capture Clash for sponsoring
this video check it out through the link
in the description thank you for
watching I hope you enjoyed this preview
of an awesome upcoming season I'm always
looking forward to the next video to put
out and I hope to see you next time
thank you and this is Vinnie tube
checking out